[Music]
well Canada has become just the second
country in the history of the world to
fully legalize the sale of marijuana as
well as the recreational consumption
much like young Americans young
Canadians increasingly can't afford to
buy homes or start families or even have
cars more and more of them are stuck
living at home with their parents whom
they will make less than as they get
older these are huge problems no one's
even thinking about how to fix them but
at least young people will be too high
to notice maybe they won't complain is
this idea coming to the United States of
course it is
Mason Tavern is a spokesman for the
Marijuana Policy Project he joins us
tonight Mason thanks a lot for coming on
tonight does it thank you so much for
having me of course does it bother you
when big business and government align
to make young people more passive and
compliant well it bothers me when
government creates foolish laws that
destroy the lives of countless young and
older people alike for using a substance
that's objectively less harmful than
alcohol and you know right
marijuana is out there so rather than
forcing it into the underground market
criminalizing people for using it let's
actually control it let's regulate it
let's treat it more like alcohol and do
what we can to minimize the potential
harm around it right I mean we're not
doing thing to minimize the harm around
it obvious so we're never going to do
that in fact it's become more potent and
by the way I would concede that in a lot
of ways alcohol is more threatening than
marijuana for sure but it's also less
deadening and that's kind of the point
about marijuana government isn't in the
marijuana business because it wants to
minimize harm it wants to make money and
tax revenue but it also wants to keep
young people passive and stupid and less
likely to complain and revolt when the
economy they've created doesn't serve
young people you don't see this I think
it's actually kind of an absurd notion
seeing as marijuana's long been
associated with younger people revolting
I mean marijuana became popular in the
60s during the anti-war movement and
Mason come on now come on now I grew up
in calc
I knew it marijuana is it does not make
you more likely to do anything is the
truth as you know I know first and
karyotype it's not a it's very
intentional reality it's like saying
everyone enjoys a cocktail after work
with their friends is a lush it's just
not true I'm not arguing news cannabis
it's not a big deal I mean the last few
presidents the last you know we've had
Supreme Court justices we have countless
businesspeople I mean it's not you're
totally missing it I'm not I'm not
arguing that I'm not arguing it is a
problem for people to smoke marijuana
occasional I don't think it is I'm not a
prohibitionist by temperament at all and
I'm not a neo Puritan unlike everyone on
their left I'm just saying if you make
it legal many more young people will use
it much more often this we know it's
true of everything that's actually not
what we're seeing if you look at is what
is illegal has not seen an increase in
teen years that's not true actually and
spare me okay governments in each of
those states okay but let me just ask
you though over populations it is true
that marijuana and this is a clinical
matter that has been studied
longitudinally of a lot over decades
makes people less likely to act it makes
them more passive and I'm just saying if
you were running a system that was not
serving young people serving them so
badly a lot of them became socialists
wouldn't you want them passive and
Spacey and out of it and wouldn't you
also want to collect the tax revenue and
continue your alliance with creepy big
cannabis companies I mean that's kind of
what's going on right
I honestly I think it's bizarre that you
want the government to use this as a way
to criminalize a whole population of
people and control the people but that
is what they're doing all you want it to
be a crime for adults to use a substance
less harmful than one that's legal or no
you or me or anyone but whatever what
I'm saying is a marijuana already was
effectively decriminalized in
most-played not every place and there
are people who did jail terms for weed
no yes there's a thousands of
okay that's it every year for me no
that's not no no no no one in most
places is arrested for a joint look we
have a Don't Ask Don't Tell policy
places a hundred thousand Americans are
arrested every year of the marijuana
they and that's you but hold on
you could very easily in effect
decriminalize it for small amounts
without legalizing which means every
time I walk through Times Square someone
is hitting a vape or smoking a joint
which is what it is now I'm saying it's
a totally different thing as you know
but big companies drop it and don't you
see what you're saying is that it's
illegal in Time Square the point of
saying it's already been decriminalized
as you know like in New York City in
Washington DC it's legal and people
smoke it on the street people smoke more
it's not straight and if you do you're
gonna get cited just like you're right
if you were tunneling up your own yeah I
thought you did this for a living that's
not true you don't get nothing happens
if you if you can prove it's legal to
use marijuana on us three you're missing
my point it's not enforced as you know
de Blasio said two cops I just talked to
what about it's not enforced oh that's
better than legalizing it the only thing
that we'll do is make us more the
government third thing I've ever heard
you did not know facts it say you're
denying the allegations and thousands of
people are arrested in New York every
year for marijuana possession it's just
a fact conspiracy well it's literally
that but it's also a conspiracy but
people like you to get rich from selling
it let's be honest this is big
corporations trying to get rich from
getting kids to smoke more wheat and I'm
sure you've got a piece of it don't give
me that personal freedom garbage this is
another so corporations should be like
do you think course I'm not saying it
should be the adviser Bush evil
corporations and that they're they're
just out there to destroy I think that
painting no not to destroy the world but
I think people to push you think though
you think that alcohol should be illegal
not be there
lacking right yeah the product is the
product now it like destroys people I've
seen it anywhere at a time I wish we
could keep going because you know what
good to see you